[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui vous amène aujourd'hui
j'ai envie de changer mais en même temps
je ne suis pas tout à fait disposé à
faire des efforts je fais de mon mieux
et à chaque fois que je me débarrasse
d'une obsession et notre obsession la
remplacer vous venez de pailler je suis
coincé et chaque jour ce serait
peut-être
ok qu'est-ce que vous ressentez
[Musique]
il faut que je te pose une question tu
vas être comme ça pour toujours j'en
sais rien
[Musique]
je suis simplement inquiet pour toi ça
fait un an que je fais mon deuil c'est
pas ce que j'appelle deuil
je déteste la tête d'enterrement c'est
mon visage j'ai toujours une tête de
chien battu il n'arrêtait pas de dire et
de redire combien j'étais débile mais
voilà il m'aime
votre mari vous fait subir des violences
morales il ne cherche pas à changer et
le temps n'y fera rien mais plaquer le
bordel
d'accord
Paul je crois que je suis capable
d'aider ces gens si je prends des
risques votre mère voulait que vous
répondiez ces cendres c'est ça ou c'est
bien ce qu'il doit faire ça vous arrive
de vouloir appeler secouer on se retient
on fait oublier courez
un terme à ta carrière et m'entraîner
avec toi on le fait un pile ou face
allez
réagir plus vite
les patientes se sont jamais aussi bien
portées ça marche plutôt bien
personne n'échappe ça fait partie de la
vie j'arrive plus à me rappeler de maman
elle est en train de disparaître je le
sens
tu as toujours le choix soit tu te
laisses submerger par ce qui t'arrive
soit tu prends la décision d'aller
d'avant
tu vas laisser ta bagnole ici je suis un
mec blanc à pas ça Dénat les flics vont
probablement la déposer chez moi pour
moi c'est un pote
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut Derek ça va je promène le chien
que je voulais pas impatiente à emménagé
dans la maison de sa sœur on dirait que
la journée commence merveilleusement
bien pour nous
[Musique]